Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call.
A bunch of questions that came in will get to those first.
But feel free to use your chat function on the Zoom to chat in any questions that you have.
I'm going to show up in the chat box.
Okay, let's jump into the questions as we've been running long lately.
If anybody have shorter answers.
Okay, first question.
Is there a blood test to show that I'm getting better?
How can I tell?
Maybe, maybe not.
So there's no perfect way to know whether our cancer is shrinking or not.
Even in, you know, with gold standard testing.
That is like PET scans and MRIs or CT scans.
I've always said that it's good to, you know, compare apples to apples.
Meaning that, okay, if the size of your breast tumor was determined by an MRI,
how am I going to know if it's shrinking unless I do another MRI.
Preferably from the same place, preferably read by the same radiologist.
No, I don't, none of those things are, you know, a given.
But you're trying to be as close to comparison from size by using the same type of scans.
So if you did a breast ultrasound, it'd be better to go to the same ultrasound facility and get the ultrasound read.
That way that you're going to have close to the best comparison.
Now, what if you don't have a tumor that can be measured with a scan, an ultrasound, an MRI or CT scan?
A PET scan is another way to look at things.
But of course, all these things that we're talking about except ultrasounds are invasive.
You're getting radiation when you're doing, you know, CT scans.
You're getting gadolinium usually because you have to do a contrast eye when you're doing an MRI.
So that's not always our first choice.
That's not even the question. The question is there a blood test.
So is there a blood test to know how I'm doing?
Well, if your cancer is one that shows tumor markers, that is the benefit of running tumor marker tests.
So if you have a cancer that tends to show tumor markers, then if you got a baseline
that your tumor marker is going down, that's a clue.
So I don't think any of these tests that I'm talking about are going to be perfect.
Maybe just because my tumor markers are going down does not mean that my cancer is getting better.
There's other things that you look at too.
But that is one indication that your tumor is getting better.
If your tumor marker is going up, does that mean your cancer is getting worse?
Maybe, maybe not. It's a clue that gives us, you know, reason to pause and reason to think
and you compare it with other things.
So as far as a blood test goes, those tumor markers are one thing that may be valuable.
There's other things on the blood test that can give us clues.
So if, you know, that's why I want you guys to be getting a complete comprehensive metabolic panel on a regular basis.
And a CBC, a complete blood count with differential on a regular basis.
So if my complete blood count has been normal and you're looking at these things over time, my complete blood count has been normal over time.
But now I'm starting to develop an anemia.
Does that, what does that mean?
That could be an indication that your cancer is progressing because as our cancer progresses,
one of the things that is common, it's not always present, but it's common is for an anemia to be present
because cancer can be gobbling up iron because of the high metabolic rate of the cancer.
The complete metabolic, comprehensive metabolic panel, we can be looking at two liver markers.
We could be looking at alkaline phosphatase. We could be looking at calcium markers.
So there's things that can give us clues.
But there's not going to be one thing that is going to say, oh my gosh, your cancer is absolutely getting worse.
We don't be on a shadow window because of this one test.
So you use blood work to give us clues to maybe dig a little deeper.
Plus you use subjective findings as well. Am I feeling better or am I feeling worse?
So you put all these pieces of the puzzle together to come up with a diagnosis,
whether you're the progression of the cancer, whether it's getting better or it's getting worse.
Historically, I have had occasional cold source, usually following times of stress.
Since starting the Joe Tippen's protocol nearly two years ago, however,
I have had nearly constant battle with cold source. One of follows another.
I'm using the rife, I present for cold source, which has been very helpful except for one incredibly powerful outbreak that covered half of my lower lip line.
I'm wondering if you think there could be a connection between these crazy constant outbreaks and the Joe Tippen's protocol.
Could these so cold source be some kind of a herx reaction?
Well, I do not think that there are herx reactions.
So first of all, you have to understand what cold source are.
Herpes, simplex virus that lives in the ganglion of the nerve.
So viruses are very difficult to kill.
Some people have believed that they're not even living things that can be killed.
So it is for certain that they are extremely difficult to kill.
People that have cold source, if they have cold source in your mouth, that's an outbreak of that virus that comes down the nerve ganglion.
Typically, the virus lives in the trigeminal nerve ganglion, which is up by your jaw joint.
That's your fifth cranial nerve.
And then opportunistically, it can come down that nerve and then expose as a lesion in your mouth or on your lips.
What's the opportunistic reason why they come out?
Well, you stated right here that it can come out in times of stress.
Why is that?
Well, it's typically believed that anything that can change the pH of your mouth drastically can cause this opportunity for the herpy simplex virus to come out.
That's why if you sucked on a lemon, people say, oh, I sucked on a lemon and I got a cold sore.
Or I drank a bunch of lemon juice and I started getting cold sore breakouts because you changed the pH of your mouth.
Well, under stress, you change the pH that changes the pH of your mouth.
Could it be a herx reaction that's causing this to come out?
No, because the definition of a herx reaction is when toxins that is endotoxins that are created from die-off of cells,
I mean, typically a herx reaction is from die-off bacteria in your body that overwhelms the detoxification pathways.
That means endotoxins, it's parts of the bacteria, organism itself as it explodes and bursts apart through cell lysis, you're killing that bacteria.
It has to detox out of your body and it can overwhelm your liver detox pathways and you can feel malaise and feel icky.
So, it's definitely not that.
Now, I don't know any drugs.
So, first of all, let's take a step back.
What is a Joe Tippen's protocol?
Joe Tippen's protocol is using fenbenazol.
So, can fenbenazol cause a change in the pH of your mouth?
I don't know.
I looked up some, tried to find some data on that and there is none.
So, certainly any drug can do have all sorts of crazy effects on different people.
So, I would say, you know, if you narrowed it down to, okay, it all started.
When I started the Joe Tippen's protocol, I'm pretty hard to make a big argument about that unless something else changed in your life at that time.
And I would certainly say that any type of medication could have that effect on you.
So, I would, you know, the only way to absolutely know for sure is to go off of it for a period of time.
And there wouldn't be anything wrong with pulsed it.
Maybe go off for two weeks, see if that clears things up.
And wow, that really clears things up.
And maybe you can go back on that again.
So, that's what I would think, and that's what I would suggest if the pulsars are driving you crazy.
Is there some sort of progression of symptoms when someone has lymphoma and then starts your life and supplement program?
Do people go through different stages before they're cancer-free?
How soon will there be changes? It's been two months and I've not really noticed any decrease in the intra abdominal mass.
Well, three days ago, I started having pain in that area.
Is that a sign that the immune system is attacking that area?
Well, I do have a video and a blog post on good-paid, bad-paid that will maybe help you discern that.
There's no perfect way to discern whether my pain is a good-paid or a bad-paid.
And you say, well, how could there be any good-paid?
Well, if your immune system is attacking a site, you're going to have an increase in inflammation at that site.
That's what an uptick of the immune system is.
So you get a B bite, a B sting, and you have all this inflammation because of the B sting, because your immune system is setting this entire immune attack, try to deal with this inflammatory thing that is pulsating toxins into your system.
So the same thing when you're up trying to uptick your immune system to fight a cancer, you could have an increase in inflammation at that site and have pain because of that.
So I don't know if that's a good-paid or a bad-paid.
If you're saying that you can feel like you are able to adequately examine a mass, whether it's a breast mass or a mass that's from lymphoma, and it adequately measure the size, and you can say, after two months, it's not changing size.
Does that mean it's a bad thing?
Maybe, maybe not. So remember, when we're trying to kill cancer, we're trying to extend someone's life or not.
I don't get our mind where I was thinking, I want this to go away.
You have a mass in your breast or you have a mass in your abdominal cavity and it's lymphoma or it's a breast cancer.
I want this to go away. Of course, we all want it to go away. But really, what do you think about it? What is cancer?
Cancer is rapidly replicating cells. If we could stop it rapidly replicating, and our body would just wall it off, wouldn't that be just as good?
Well, maybe mentally, it would be better for you or me to have it disappear, and then we don't see it anymore. But realistically, when you have a fairly large mass, it's going to be more difficult for the body to remove that mass, to break it down, to get it out of your body, to get rid of the cells, and for you to detox it,
as it would be for your body to wall it off and have it not grow. Really, we want a mass to stop growing. Of course, I agree. We want it to go away.
But we want it to stop growing as far as how long does it take for that to take place? Well, to be honest, we may have to tweak your program and change things to get it moving in that right direction.
But also, honestly, it may take months for it, just put the brakes on it to start shrinking, and then thirdly, it may just stop growing and be walled off and never change size.
If you live another 40 years with this mass of dead cells in your abdominal cavity, that's a possibility too.
So, how do we know what is happening with that? The only perfect way to know if a mass that has not changed size, let's say it's not getting bigger.
It's not getting smaller. It's still the same size. Let's say now it's going to be two months out or two years out.
How would we know if this is still active cancer or not? The only way to know at that point would be to go in and remove it and then do a pathology report on it.
So, you cut it in slices and you look at it at a microscope if they're all dead cells. Of course, you're always going to do that because there's danger of that too.
I actually had this story multiple times that I had a lung cancer patient who had multiple masses in her chest.
And she refused to let the surgeon remove them. He was trying to get her to remove them. I can't remember how long of a time it was. Finally, she was persuaded.
This was a surgeon at Mayo that talked her into doing it. He said it was going to be a relatively quick surgery. The surgery took like five times longer than he thought because the tumors that he thought was active cancer was just walled off dead cells.
That broke apart like he the work he used the surgeon used was he broke a broke apart like a puff ball and it made a mess in that person's lungs and it took forever to clean it out.
So, maybe you should have let sleeping giants lie. You know, I'm not saying that's the case we need to measure. We need to look at all sorts of different things.
Like I said, with that previous question, look at blood work and look at scans and and look at subjective findings as well.
So, I'm feeling great. I'm feeling fantastic. If I still have this mass, it's not getting any bigger, but it's concerning because it's not getting any smaller.
Well, you weigh it out with as many possible things that you could do to weigh out whether I'm getting better or not.
Can you explain again what the mycotox test measures? So, the mycotox test is testing toxins that molds and fungi produce.
So, the molds and the fungi are living organisms. They produce toxins. So, let's say if I have mold, black mold growing on the wall in my bathroom, how is that dangerous to me?
Well, that black mold is going to give off spores, mold spores and that's how that mold reproduces.
So, those spores will travel through the air to find another moist organic spot to grow. So, mold needs a moist organic spot.
So, it grows on wood, it grows on paper. So, sheet rock is a great wet sheet rock. Wet wood is a great breeding ground for these mold spores.
So, they start to reproduce and it starts to grow. And as it grows, it gives off spores. Well, if I breed in those spores, I could have living mold spores in my lungs because I breed them in.
And I could, if my immune system isn't adequately killing it, I could end up with a fungal infection in my lungs.
So, I could have an aspergillus fungal infection in my lungs that could cause fungal pneumonia. And that could be very serious. You could die from that. So, it's very serious, especially if someone's immune compromised.
So, mold spores, breed it in, are not good. There's different molds that happen down in southern states, like in Arizona, the red, I think it's called red tide or something that happens with certain winds.
It was on hot days with the climate is perfect and such that it can bring in these different types of mold spores that people can get quite sick.
That's not what this test is testing for. The other thing that black mold in my bathroom can give does give off are inert substances, toxins.
So, toxins are also produced by mold by different fungi. And those have been called, you know, microtoxins as a group, as a classification of these kind of toxins that these molds can give off.
So, microtoxins are also dispersed into the air and we can breathe those in. We breathe in those microtoxins. These things can go across our alveolar spaces and are elongated to our bloodstream.
And hopefully our liver is going to be able to detoxify and dump them into the colon and we exit them into the toilet.
But many times they stay in our system. So, remember our degree of toxicity at any given time is equal to the rate of toxic substance that we're exposed to and the quantity of toxic substance that I'm exposed to, minus my ability to get rid of them, minus my ability to detox them.
So, if I ever am exposed to high amount of poisons of any kind, exceed my livers and my kidneys rate of detoxification, those toxins will then be deposited in my extracellular spaces and then go into my cells.
And once these toxins sit in my cells, they tend to just sit there and they don't multiply because they're not living organisms, they're just poisons that sit there and they can interrupt cell function, they can interrupt other organelles of the cytoplasm, they can damage the mitochondria, they can cause fatigue.
And if they damage the nucleus, they can cause rapid replication, aka cancer. So, these toxins in the mycotoxin test, almost all of them are classified as carcinogens because if they get inside the cell, they can damage the nucleus and cause cancer.
So, what we're measuring in the mycotox test are mycotoxins, these poisons, these chemicals that mold produce. So, if you have elevated level of mycotoxins on the mycotox test, you were exposed to these, either
through a black mold, from moldy building syndrome, or they can be in foods, coffee, peanuts, other nuts, grains that were stored and had too high of a moisture content and mold grew on it and then the granary, you know, general meals grounded up into flour and sold it as flour.
And you never knew the mycotoxin content, and you ate that flour and now you absorb them across your gut, absorption sites and they're in your body the same way as if you breathe them in.
So, that's where, that's what the mycotoxin is measuring. So, what we, when I do this test on you and you have elevated mycotoxins, we want to use some things that will help keylate and bind these and pull these out of your body, but that will do little good if you're, if you're continually exposed to these things.
So, I mean, there's a certain level of mycotoxins that you're going to be continually exposed to no matter what, I mean, just like the toxic tech test, you can't run away from all this stuff, you can't go live in a bubble, you just can't.
Even if you live in a plastic bubble, there's toxins from the plastic that you get from that, you'd still have toxins.
We live in a poisoned world, it just is what it is. So, you have to mitigate as best you possibly can, but certainly you're the worst concentration of these are going to be in moldy buildings, so if you have mold in your house that you haven't investigated and dealt with, well, you're, you're never going to get better.
It's just you're just never going to win that battle. That's really, really difficult. So, now you can stop eating peanut butter, you can stop eating as much as many grains, but it's, you know, you could look at that mycotox test and see the, the sources and there's a lot of sources for these toxins. So, you do the best that you possibly can.
Could mold in my water system because in high mycotox results, the well has been tested for bacteria and E. coli, but having trouble finding a test for mold.
Yeah, there's not a test for mold that I know of in your, for your well.
And there I, I, to answer the question, could mold in my water system because in high mycotox results, I don't think so. I don't think so. I've not seen any data on that.
Your well is a steel pipe. It's not an organically, remember, mold wants to grow on an organic substance like a wood or a paper or something like that. It's not going to grow on metal.
So, your, your metal steel pipe that's in the ground, bringing water from down in a, the water source, it's not, that's not going to be a mold source. So, I wouldn't, it can be a bacterial source, but it's not going to be a mold source.
I just finished with, an appointment with my functional doctor to try to bring down my homocysteine level. She is recommended Resveratrol 250 to 500 milligrams per day plus an AC 600 milligrams a day, any objections or concerns.
Well, there's no objection to Resveratrol.
The only thing that a comment I'll make about Resveratrol, I mean, this is a good dosage and I would agree that is, that would be, that may be helpful.
The only thing I would say is if you could get it in smaller milligram capsules like 50 or 100 milligram capsules and split it up through the day, Resveratrol,
then all your nutrients have a half-life, meaning that, okay, if I take 100 milligrams of Resveratrol in, let's say, I absorbed 100 milligrams of Resveratrol in, in what period of time will now I only have 50 milligrams circulating in my body.
And then what period of time will I have 25 milligrams in 12.5? That's a half-life.
Out of all your nutrition, Resveratrol has been found to have the shortest half-life. It is literally a matter of minutes.
So Resveratrol is one of those supplements. If you're going to take it, you want to break up the dose.
So that's my comment on that. And as you know, cystine, I don't know about that, bringing down homocystine levels.
So the pathway, so homocystine is at the end path of the methionine cycle.
So I should have pulled up my chart. So homocystine is at the end point of the methionine cycle, that then goes into the transulferation pathway.
And that is the pathway that you make glutathione.
Edicidal cystine is a precursor to glutathione.
So I guess I could see if there is a blockage in that pathway that the building blocks of glutathione may help.
I don't think it's a problem.
A standard answer to this for cancer patients would be no to the edicidal cystine.
Because we don't want to use edicidal cystine to build glutathione in a patient with cancer.
Because if you have extra glutathione with cancer, you do stand the chance of keeping the cancer cells alive.
But sometimes glutathione can be beneficial for other reasons for short-term use.
So I don't see any problem with using this for short-term use for you at all.
So to answer your question, I don't see any objections or concerns if you're planning on doing this for a couple of months to see if we can move the homocystine levels.
Following my ZRT test, and I think this person is talking about methylated estrogens.
She says to help me methylate my tooth, that's a two hydroxyesterolds.
Better, she wants to try phosphatital colon, B6, and 400 milligrams, B2 riboflavin.
Do you see any objections or concerns with that?
I noticed the store's body bio has soy less than, is that important, whether it's organic soy.
So this, I believe, is organic soy and this is almost every phosphatital colon is going to be from soy.
Phosphatital colon, what is phosphatital colon?
Phosphatital colon is the building block of all your cells.
So I have no trouble with you taking this.
Is phosphatital colon a contraindicated for people with cancer?
No, not at all.
All your cell membranes are built with phosphatital colon, and so is all your brain cells.
So it's good for that as well.
So no, I don't have a problem with this.
I would say yes to that, go with that protocol and see if we get that down or get your two hydroxyesterolds.
The next question I was submitted by a person I've broken into multiple questions here.
They first thanked me for what we do, and I appreciate that, so thank you for being so thankful.
And they asked me about different products here.
Now, some of these I don't test for.
I want to.
Most products when when people ask me about what about this project, I take this, I take this.
The majority of them, I can honestly say, I tested for that.
We don't need to take that yet.
And if you're really interested in it, it doesn't mean you still can't take it.
But I may have a day or day on these products.
So let's kind of go through these.
This person, what do you think about cell food or halox for oxygenation of cells?
Okay, so cell food is a product on the market.
I am familiar with that.
Cell food is a product that is.
It's got deuterium sulfate in it.
And it is kind of sold as a oxidizer of tissue.
I, you know, there's a lot of products.
I understand first of all, so I don't want to be mean to different supplements that are on the market.
But there's a lot of different supplements on the market that are based on really great science sometimes.
So I struggle with them.
And some of them are put out by like multi level marketing companies and I don't have anything technically against a multi level marketing company.
But sometimes I think that they may be more positioned in selling a hype on a product that they aren't really knowing what the product does.
So I just, I just want to state that I'm not saying that any of these companies do that.
I'm just saying that we got to be careful with what we read out on the internet.
So cell food is a deuterium sulfate product.
Now I struggle with that because I have some videos on.
Another cancer treatment, which is deuterium depleted water.
So take a step back.
What is deuterium?
So deuterium is an isotope of hydrogen.
So hydrogen is is is is an H atom that has just has no neutron.
Deuterium is is an H atom attached to an O2 that has an extra neutron so it has a neutron.
Now that makes so there's hydrogen water.
Water is H2O.
Two Hs which have a negative electron charge attached to an oxygen.
And so hydrogen have a positive charge doesn't have it doesn't have a neutron attached to an oxygen.
So two hydrogens have to attach to an oxygen which has a negative charge.
And then then you have water and we drink water and all the water in the universe here all the water in our world is H2O.
But hydrogen in water can exist as a deuterium hydrogen O2.
So it's still H2O but it is a heavier hydrogen.
So it's actually been termed heavy water.
And there's a percentage of our water that coming out of your faucet that's coming out of the bottled water that's coming out of the ground.
You have a well that there's a percentage depending on where you live in the world.
There's a percentage of your water that is regular what's called proteum hydrogen that we would call H2O.
And there's a percentage that is deuterium hydrogen that's still H2O still two hydrogens to an oxygen.
So there's a percentage that is deuterium.
Now I can't remember I actually talked about it in the video that I made a few years ago when I was talking about deuterium depleted water.
But I think either United States or the greater percentage of United States it's like 7% of the water you drink is deuterium or something like that.
I can't remember that percentage and I didn't look up any of the stuff before this question.
So trying to just go off memory when I spoke about deuterium depleted water.
So this heavy water with this extra with some of the water be deuterium hydrogen
has been said to cause a shorter lifespan of humans.
Because it has been shown that people's one of the things of some people groups that are in blue zones.
Blue zones are people that have more satirians, more people that live over 100 years old.
There's groups of people in these blue zones.
One of the things that they found different with them is that they're drinking water that is deuterium depleted.
It's got much lower percentage of deuterium in it.
That sparked off all this investigation about two decades ago about what deuterium is and what it does to the human body.
Deuterium ages us much quicker.
Matter of fact, there's some even biblical scholars that have kind of jumped down this way and have said that maybe this is why in the old Biblical times pre-flood
that the Lucila lived 900 some years because there was no deuterium at all in the atmosphere into the water.
So humans lived much longer.
Well, it's kind of down the rabbit hole.
I don't know if that's true or not, but there is a treatment of cancer that you could drink water that has been electronically depleted of deuterium.
The hard part is there's only a couple centers that actually produce this and it's in Europe.
Now, glacial water is deuterium depleted in itself.
So actually what's that Icelandic water bottled water that you can buy I think it's called Icelandic actually has actually is deuterium depleted water.
And a much lesser percentage that if you would spend a lot of money to buy a gallon of deuterium depleted water from the company who uses this giant filtration type system that's super, super expensive that creates deuterium depleted water.
So long story short, self food has deuterium sulfate in it.
I put a life of me when I remember a couple of years ago when a patient came and said they were taking self food I looked into that product more extensively.
I did not look and I'm sorry at all.
I just saw this question and I separated it apart and put it on this slide, you know, about 15 minutes ago.
So I didn't have a chance to dig into it again, but I remember looking at why are they selling deuterium sulfate I just for the life of me can't figure it out.
So my honest answer with with that products is I don't understand it.
And I went into this whole offshoot about deuterium and deuterium depleted water.
That's another treatment.
So I guess you could add that what about deuterium depleted water.
I actually went to a seminar with the expert of deuterium depleted water and he was a scientist that worked at the company that made the mechanism that that produced the end product and I had many chance with him because he had a lot to say there's a lot of studies about cancer.
And put some of that stuff in the slides of you to go back to our blog post is search deuterium depleted water you'll probably come up with the blog post about that.
Now halox.
So answer for self food.
I just have questions about that halox.
It depends on what we're talking about.
So I'm not totally familiar with this product.
So there is a there is a company that's called hate that has halox ointment that is a salicylic acid ointment that's supposed to just decrease paid and it's got some other things in it for inflammation.
So I don't know that that's exactly what you're talking about.
There's another product on the market that's called halox and it's it's called halo x.
So I don't know if it's halo x is what you're talking about halo x is more of a male testosterone boosted product.
So I'm not sure if you can send me more details on that on this product either one of those are what you're talking about.
I'll gladly look at that and research that can talk to you about it individually or I can talk to you about it on the next sum call.
So I apologize for that.
Next thing what do you think about potassium bicarbonate?
So potassium bicarbonate.
What is that so you've heard of sodium bicarbonate sodium bicarbonate is sodium with a carbonate bicarbonate atom attached to which is H CO3 and so potassium is a potassium atom with bicarbonate attached to it to make a potassium bicarbonate molecule.
So what would be the benefit of taking bicarbonate so you can read all sorts of cancer things to using so baking soda.
I know I'm going to take baking soda there's a video of a guy making baking soda with honey and he dissolves it in honey and he takes that every day.
I'm making that the baking soda is going to attach to the honey and now it's going to go into the cancer as a making as baking soda and the idea is that you're going to alkalize the cancer and kill the cancer by alkalizing it.
Okay so potassium bicarbonate would be an alkalizing agent sodium bicarbonate would be an alkalizing agent.
But what is it going to be alkalizing if you swallow potassium or sodium bicarbonate it's going to alkalize your stomach so let's we got to kind of take a step back again.
I've talked about this a lot in the past but I just want to go over it again you've heard it said maybe we don't hear it quite as often now but back in the days we used to hear this all the time that cancer is acidic and cancer can't grow in an alkaline environment.
That was a huge thing that alternative cancer doctors used to tout and that we need to alkalize ourselves and then they came up with these the pH strips and you could test your saliva to see if your saliva was alkaline or acidic and you could test your urine to see if that was alkaline or acidic.
And then if it was acidic all goodness that means you're going to die or get sick or something and be infecitious I apologize but then we have to alkalize ourselves so we take alkalizing things we could take sodium bicarbonate we could take potassium bicarbonate we could do other things to alkalize our tissues and then over time we measure our urine or measure our saliva.
And oh we're getting back into range we're getting our pH is getting better and and that means that my body systemically is more alkaline and I'm going to be healthier and there's books written about this and there's courses that talk about this.
I don't want to insult anybody but this is absolute nonsense it doesn't make any physiological sense so let's think of the physiology so in our body we have a pH of our body we have a pH of our tissue you have a pH of your blood that is the most important thing.
The pH of your blood has to stay within a range of about 7.2 to 7.4 it has to or you'll die if it's out of that range for any given period of time you will die so you have what's called a buffering system so your buffering system there's actually multiple buffering systems to keep the pH of your blood in that range.
So this is where your bones are living organisms they're not just hard things that hold up your body they're living organisms where minerals are going in and out of the bone constantly that's the danger of taking those drugs like zometa that actually put us like a like a cellophane wrap on your bones and create a hard riddle perioste of the outer layer of the bone and don't allow.
The minerals that are in the endopsy of the inner part of the bone to be transferred in and out of the bone to help buffer your body and keep a good acid base balance in your blood especially.
Now back to cancer is acidic it's can't live in an alkaline environment well that's not true cancer any cell that's in rapid replication is going to give off a lot of waste that waste usually is going to be acidic so I would agree that cancer cancer itself can be acidic but it's not growing because the environment is acidic.
It's growing because something got inside the cell and damaged the nucleus and caused it to go into rapid replication has nothing to do with the it was acidic in that area or something previous and has to do with something damaged the cell so
that as it rapidly replicates and rapidly replicates cells that are rapidly replicating it's producing waste and that waste has to be excluded outside of the cell membrane and goes into this matrix what's called our extra outside cellular matrix so this extra cellular matrix of waste is acidic that goes around the cancer and would it be good to alkalize that.
Yes that in fact Dr. C. Machini from Italy experimented with sticky to needle into someone's you know tissue right next to the cancer with sodium bicarbonate to try to alkalize around the cancer but he wasn't trying to alkalize the cancer to by changing the environment that the cancer is in the cancer is going to stop growing.
He's alkalizing the cancer so that your immune system can get at it to kill it because that's one of the reasons why your immune system your T cells and your natural killer cells aren't able to kill the cancer is because they can't get at it because of this waste.
So that's why it's important to your lip system to support your detoxification pathways because your lymphatic system has to carry that waste back into the venous system and then through your liver and into the toilet so.
Taking potassium bicarbonate or sodium bicarbonate orally is going to alkalize your stomach well your stomach is the only spot in your body that absolutely positively needs to keep a pH about 2.0 on a scale of zero to 14.
And acid based scale so middle neutral is 7.5 acidity is lower you need to have a very acidic stomach so the I think one of the worst things a person can be doing is taking baking soda taking access potassium bicarbonate thinking that they're helping kill the cancer the less you had a stomach cancer
I don't think I think that's a very bad thing to do because you're going to you're going to alkalize your stomach and you're going to set up yourself for all sorts of indigestion issues leaky got issues.
H pylora is going to grow like crazy you're set yourself up for a world of global cold morbidity hurts if you do that so I'm not for taking potassium bicarbonate I will say if you study my chronic disease and autoimmune course there is a treatment for somebody who especially with Hashimoto's is common with Hashimoto's but it can become with some other autoimmune issues is that person can have never
with autoimmune issues salt sodium chloride can be a trigger and sodium and potassium have a balance in your blood so remember when you have looked at your comprehensive metabolic panel you one of the things that it measures is your sodium and your potassium and you want that ratio to be good you don't you want you don't want excess potassium you don't want
you don't want excess sodium that in fact if person does have excess potassium and low sodium that's typically a sign of dehydration but one treatment for somebody who's sensitive to sodium because it's some autoimmune diseases especially Hashimoto's can have a sodium sensitivity so that could be a trigger in the person's autoimmune disease so if they eat foods with sodium
then it's advised that they eat take potassium with the sodium doesn't have to be by a carbonate but it has to be a potassium with the sodium so that's different whole different thing we're talking about with that that we're talking about taking potassium by carbonate for cancer so I hope that was understandable but potassium by carbonate for cancer is going to alkalize your stomach set you up for a ton of possible cold morbidity
possible cold morbidities including rampant H. Pylora issues so I'm not a fan of sodium by carbonate or potassium by carbonate for a cancer therapy what do we think about methylene blue? Well methylene blue is great so I think methylene blue has been shown with some people to be super beneficial for cancer it's very anti inflammatory it's I think it shines even more
with brain inflammation so but to help ward off dementia to decrease inflammation in the brain you know given other issues so even if I have let's say a lymphoma and you know it's you know in my abdominal cavity can methylene blue help it can so methylene blue is one of those like fentanyzol and I've hermectin some people it doesn't work with how much
it doesn't work with help their cancer at all and just because there's tons of testimonials for that we have tons of testimonials for the right we have tons of testimonials for you know mushrooms we have tons of testimonials for everything it just means it doesn't mean it's going
to save for everyone so we just have to keep that in balance but I mean there really is no harm to foul and tried methylene blue versus versus fentanyzol which can have side effects and can affect your liver can affect your kidneys and like somebody else said it's causing issues with
you know their possible cold source and some weird side effects and I have hermectin is a drug and so somebody asked a question last week should I can I take I have hermectin you know even if I'm in my cancer is stable and I just want to stay healthy I would not be something I would do it's a drug still
methylene blue isn't really a drug so methylene blue is not going to have there's like no known side effects for methylene blue so I would say if you take it within the normal dose the standard dose you're going to be just fine I don't see any problem with taking it
now I've seen videos of people going absolute gonzo on methylene blue because oh if this is good for you then 10 times more must be even better for you
if you're a barricot misnomer on everything so we got to keep a balance of that so I don't I don't have any I don't have any problem with methylene blue
any thoughts on B pollen for boosting immune system well I'm a huge fan of B pollen so B pollen is great there's this is to be B pollen isn't a supplement B pollen is a food so
there's no no negatives for B pollen really have to be careful with with any like you're talking about immune boosting just remember that if you have an autoimmune disease to
in your boosted your immune system too much you could end up with flares of your autoimmune disease so if you want more data on that go to the chronic disease at autoimmune course so remember
we're trying to keep a balance with the numbers of supplements that we're giving a person because we don't want other issues to come up
we also realize that it's a pretty good chance that most people have an autoimmune disease that maybe hasn't been diagnosed yet so I'm not against trying it
they should just be aware of that things could flare in a you know we take more immune stimulants than you need you could be flared in autoimmune issues so just keep that in mind
I had asked you earlier about getting blood TB test instead of the skim test and you agreed that the blood test might be safer could you order for me through Rupa I chatted with them
and they have a blood TB test the quarter yes I can see if we can get that on our Rupa site yes they have different ones at different price levels but they start at 97 50 so please let's go with the cheapest possible
this is just for voluntary data nursing home well that's good news how to even know that existence so you guys are so smart learn something from you every day so yes we can if you want to call and talk to Angie tomorrow maybe we can get that going
so no questions on the chat so are we done for the night or do you guys have some more questions all right well thanks you guys for tonight we'll be back next week and the person who asked the question about the hey locks if you could get me more information
which product that you were talking about that I could get more specific kind of answer all right we'll talk to everybody next week bye bye